all right Joe Biden's weakness on the
world stage is now emboldening our
adversaries earlier today a US Navy
vessel shot down another drone that was
launched by the houti rebels in Yemen
over the Red Sea but despite the growing
number of attacks from the rebel groups
all senior Biden officials told Politico
that the administration is wary of
retaliating why anyway meanwhile a new
report says the White House interns the
interns are now rebelling against the
administration in a letter demanding a
ceasefire in Israel now I would say
there is a simple solution for these
interns fire them all is that
easy here with this very unique reaction
Louisiana Senator John Kennedy you know
Senator great to have
you I've had a lot of interns work on
the show over the year I can't think of
a bad one that I've ever had but if a
group of interns ever pulled anything
like that on me I would say
bye-bye who's who's running that white
house because they have been taught
this we now know that many of our young
people believe in uh
diversity
Equity
inclusion and the right to kill
Jews and they don't see the
inconsistency in that they don't see the
irony in
that and and I think the reaction of
most fair-minded Americans to that
position certainly my reaction is pass
me the sick
bucket um I agree with you if I were
President Biden I would call all of my
interns in and tell them I'm sorry
they're upset they should go by an
emotional support Pony but they're fine
um I don't think President Biden will do
this I I can't
imagine I can't imagine working for an
employer it's okay to disagree with your
boss but uh I can't imagine working for
an employer writing him a formal letter
leaking it to
NBC and then
daring the the employer to do something
about it and probably the White House
will do nothing about it just like they
have done very little to deter our
enemies throughout the world let me ask
you about China for example uh we see
them confronting our fighter jets in
international airspace they confront our
Navy in international waters uh the Spy
balloon unfair Trade Practices uh we we
we don't have free and fair trade uh
intellectual property theft spy balloons
all all this combined and Joe Biden has
done nothing what does that say about
Joe Biden do you think in any way it
might be connected to all the money that
the Biden family made out of
China well what it tells me is that uh
the Biden Administration would rather
would rather debate whether men can
breastfeed than protect the interests of
this country look reality has a way of
bruising people that don't respect it
and the sad reality is that our enemies
China Russia North Korea Iran are not
scared of President
Biden um and for good reason it was
President Biden who who abandoned
Afghanistan it was President Biden Who
removed the sanctions on Russia's
nordstream two pipeline it was President
Biden who killed F the FBI's China
initiative it was President Biden who
has refused to give Ukraine the weapons
that it need needs to win it was
President Biden Who removed the
sanctions on Venezuela it was President
Biden who re refuses to respond to the
recent attacks on on American troops by
Iran in Syria and Iraq and the Red
Sea I think if uh President Biden had
been president when Japan attacked Pearl
Harbor he he would have appointed a task
force to see what we did to offend them
let me ask you Senator let me ask you
this can you name a single thing a
single policy that Joe Biden has
implemented that has benefited the
American people because I
cannot I can't I I'm I'm trying I want
to be fair to the president I don't hate
anyone but I I just uh I can't and and
and our enemies Sean see what a majority
of the American people
see this may not be fair fair or unfair
accurate or inaccurate our enemies and a
majority of Americans think the
president is older than time his family
has corruption problems and the vice
president his vice president is weak and
people act accordingly we cannot have
you on enough let's give a big hand
Senator hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else